one of our show's sponsors subway would
like us to tell you about their great
new sub of the day deal featuring a
different 6-inch Subway sandwich every
day of the week for just 350 hey Conan
what about this sweet onion chicken
teriyaki sandwich those are my favorite
well sure Andy they're the subway some
of the day on Mondays Oh today's
Thursday yeah well I guess I have no
choice but to climb into that highly
experimental time machine over there
travel back in time to Monday and get a
sweet deal on one of those six-inch
sweet onion chicken teriyaki Subway
sandwiches wait okay or you could wait
until Monday and just walk into some way
to get the deal can't hear you getting
into a time alone no that's a mistake
sweet onion chicken teriyaki sandwich
here I come
[Applause]
[Applause]
that's incredible you did it any I just
got a sweet onion chicken teriyaki
Subway sandwich for just 350 yeah and
all you had to do was risk your life
with dangerous unproven technology yeah
who's the idiot now every teacher I ever
had
don't mind if I do
president Lian Wow well I just took this
very small incident doesn't change
history in any way maybe the history of
advertising
oh no look tone and it's too late what
[Applause]
you